[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you get assassinated historically
that means you're probably a great
leader
for me a leader is anybody who has
people they're responsible for
if you give anyone absolute power giving
a saint an absolute power
is innately a really bad idea hello and
welcome to today's debate on leadership
hypocrisy and power my name is miriam
francois
welcome now great leaders promise
to change the world they claim to have
the vision and the values to transform
our lives but rarely do they deliver
again and again the promises are not
kept the transformation
fails to arrive and instead there is
incompetence
deceit and duplicity not to mention
corruption are leaders a singularly
useless and malevolent bunch or could it
be
that the hypocrisy is in fact ours
demanding ethical standards we don't
apply to ourselves
and which no one can live up to and
expecting leaders implausibly
to solve intractable problems once and
for all
would we be better to stop vilifying our
politicians and leaders
and focus on the complexity and
challenge of finding the best solutions
or is it simply the case that absolute
power
corrupts absolutely and should we
redouble
our oversight to ensure they remain in
check
now to help answer these questions and
many more i'm joined by
a fantastic panel kicking off it with
chris hurst who is a change agent
widely recognized as an innovative and
inspirational leader
he's global ceo of havash creative
and recently published his first book no
[ __ ] leadership
why the world needs more everyday
leaders and why that leader
is you next up joseph j ellis is one of
america's leading scholars of history
ellis was awarded the pulitzer prize for
founding brothers the revolutionary
generation
and won the national book award for
american sphinx
a biography of thomas jefferson and
last but certainly not least we have
natalie bennett natalie is a british
politician
and journalist who served as leader of
the green party of england and wales
from 2012 to 2016
and who now sits in the house of lords
welcome
to our panel thank you for joining us
our
leaders are singularly useless and
malevolent bunch
as some people seem to think natalie do
you want to kick us off on that one
certainly well um to start with i have
to say that
when the how the light gets in was
formulating this i suspect they may have
been looking
very hard at either westminster or uh
perhaps at the uh the trump white house
a few months ago
um and you know it's a very easy set of
labels to apply and there's definitely
some truths in them
uh but if you look around the world um
if this is all leaders then that's
clearly not the case
uh you know the obvious example that
comes to mind is jacinda ahern
in new zealand who's been doing great
things not just in tacting the pandemic
but also in terms of offering real
leadership
on environmental issues on social issues
on working with the indigenous people in
new zealand not doing perfectly but
making real progress
and even you know somewhat closer to
home angela merkel
lots of people are now she doesn't come
from my side of politics but lots of
people are now wondering you know how
is not just germany but europe got to
work without that
but i think you know some of your
introduction really gave us some sense
of
where the problems lie here the idea of
great leaders
if you call someone a great leader
that's really not good for anyone's
mental health and well-being and the
kind of way they're going to operate
um if you um if you talk about absolute
power and if you give
anyone absolute power giving a saint an
absolute power
is innately a really bad idea so you
know i think
the question in this debate is focused
very much on individuals but what we
have to do
is ask um where are the real leaders in
our society and i'm talking to you from
sheffield in northern england
you know up the hill from me there's a
there's a council estate that's got some
real problems of poverty and inequality
but there's some great people there
doing community work growing food
getting food to people who really need
it there's brilliant you know
in britain there's millions of great
leaders doing great things what we
really have to do is question what we
mean by leader
and ensure that we acknowledge that we
have any country has millions of them
thank you natalie joe are leaders a
singularly useless and malevolent bunch
as some people seem to think depends on
where you want to land in history to
answer that question
if you land in the present as the
earlier speaker
mentioned and you look at great britain
and the united states in recent years
you'd be very troubled um uh
if you look at the american founding um
it's a pretty impressive group of men um
and who uh did about the best one can
expect of an emerging power
and what made it work at that moment
which relates to the question
is a diversity of temperaments and
ideologies that interacted in such a way
to balance each other and
to avert the kind of extremism that
dictators will eventually be able to
bring to bear
in places like well napoleon uh stalin
lenin now are the are those people
leaders
um well yeah they certainly are i mean
look at nuremberg
um uh but they take a nation
in each of those cases in a direction
that uh
that history records and judges to be
the wrong direction
i think the greatest leader in the 20th
century
is the man who rescues
india from the british empire one of the
historical tests of a great leader
who is not too far out of pub far ahead
of public opinion in a democracy because
you can't be
is i mean in the united states the three
greatest leaders of all time
are george washington abraham lincoln
and martin luther king
the last two of them got assassinated if
you get assassinated
historically that means you're probably
a great leader
so what do you expect the problem is
expectation
american novelist once said that every
book in america could be called great
expectations
um and um the problem is in
our s our our expectations of the people
we elect
for or we choose um but democracies
uh worldwide or any kind of popular
opinion worldwide has a tendency
towards charismatic leadership which is
dangerous
and leads you to the dictatorial pattern
that destroys the very thing that you're
supposed to be
creating thank you so much uh joe chris
uh three minutes on our leaders a
singularly useless and malevolent bunch
so my short answer is no i don't think
most leaders are uh
but for me most leaders um
and natalie is touched on this for me
most leaders are not prime ministers
politicians ceos and generals
for me a leader is anybody who has
people they're responsible for
and by that definition there are
certainly hundreds of thousands in the
uk
and possible and certainly millions
around the world so
whether you run the projects natalie was
talking about in sheffield a hospital
a school a startup or a government
department or you know you're a leader
um and i think one of the greatest and
most damaging fallacies of the subject
of leadership
is that it's some exalted state you know
a secret knowledge
available only to a chosen few and for
me everybody has the potential to lead
there's no leadership type
and therefore no innate leadership
characteristic
good or bad um and though so i
definitely don't think all leaders are
useless and malevolent i do think
there's a vacuum i do think we need more
better leaders everywhere
again from hospitals to government and i
think leadership is difficult but not
complicated
and there's a whole industry the
leadership industrial complex if you
like
that makes millions possibly billions
from persuading us of the exact opposite
from persuading us that there is some
secret
knowledge available only to a chosen few
and i think this snake oil has two
baleful consequences i think firstly it
inhibits those already in leadership
potential
already in leadership positions from
fulfilling their potential
and as we've just established there's an
awful lot of those and i think secondly
and potentially worse it excludes whole
swathes of our society from believing
that leadership is something that they
could ever
aspire to so no i don't think all
leaders are useless but
yes i do believe that we need more
better leaders and leadership
because at the end of the day if you
look at the problems any organization
whatever it is however big it is if you
look at the problems and challenges they
face
and they all have them all the time if
you pick at that problem for long enough
if you peel away its layers like the
skin of an onion you discover at the
heart
the problem is always leadership and the
only solution to it
is better leadership so
expressed like that leadership's the
problem and the solution and i think by
wiping away the [ __ ] that surrounds
the subject and enabling and inspiring
more to lead and to lead effectively we
can
achieve amazing things as great leaders
famous and unsung let's be honest
uh have always done thank you very much
um just before we move to theme one i
know natalie you wanted to come back
quickly on something there
well i just wanted to pick up something
joe said about these in democracies
there's a tendency towards charismatic
leadership
and i think you know the example of
angela merkel for example that i gave
who you know is one of the very most
prominent leaders in the world today
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas